aujourd'hui les nouvelles technologies
ont changé à peu près tous les éléments
de notre vie au quotidien donc façon de
travailler notre façon d'avoir des
loisirs notre façon de vivre une
obligation d'acheter aujourd'hui la
question se pose de savoir quelle est la
place de l'outil numérique dans notre
démocratie
je vois qu'il ya plusieurs éléments à
prendre en compte le premier c'est que
bien sûr les réseaux sociaux ont permis
un foisonnement de l' échange de l'idée
et beaucoup de forums citoyens qui
naissent notamment la plateforme dire
qui permet à chacun de nous proposer son
idée citoyenne et de de trouver les plus
belles idées citoyennes ont chacun y va
de son initiative numérique et c'est
très bien c'est un foisonnement positif
mais c'est pas suffisant
il me semble qu'aujourd'hui la
démocratie doit intégrer l'outil
numérique pour rentrer dans un modèle
plus en continu de l'évaluation du
dialogue avec le citoyen aujourd'hui la
seule expression politique démocratique
c'est au moment du vote bien sûr c'est
un moment d'une manifestation d'une
prise de parole c'est une activité sur
les réseaux sociaux mais on pourrait
imaginer de passer à une étape
supérieure
l'étape d'après en matière de démocratie
numérique par exemple
finalement on paye nos impôts avec un
code secret un numéro de référence qu'on
a sur notre relevé d'impôts on peut
aller voir ces points retraite ou suivre
ces éléments de sécu eh bien on pourrait
imaginer une identification de chaque
citoyen comme on l'a déjà et que ses
devoirs du citoyen cette voie numérique
puis s'exprimer dans des consultations
certes sans avis impératif pour des avis
consultatifs mais qui permettrait à un
maire à l'échelle de sa commune à une
communauté de communes à l'échelle
de son territoire un département une
région à un pays de tester des idées de
susciter le débat on a vu une belle
initiative sur la noix numérique pour
essayer d'intégrer et de co construire
via des outils numériques
un projet de loi avec les citoyens je
pense que maintenant il est temps de
façon non anonymes à visage découvert ça
c'est un point fondamental
la démocratie se vit à visage des
collègues découvert par donc la
démocratie numérique aussi donc avec un
identifiant avec un référent avec sa
voix de citoyens de pouvoir être intégré
à des consultations organisées par les
élus organisée par les collectivités
organisée par le gouvernement organisée
par l'ensemble des acteurs publics pour
pouvoir imaginer une façon de garder le
pool opinion beaucoup plus proche plutôt
que d'attendre les réactions brutales de
l'opinion lorsque les ruptures comme on
peut la voir comme on l'a vu encore
récemment de différentes de différents
projets de loi et donc c'est une
démocratie numérique à réinventer c'est
ça le projet de démocratie numérique
c'est un projet qui donne enfin sa place
de façon organisée à visage découvert
mais qui redonne sa place aux citoyens
dans l'univers démocratique numérique